so where was wakabi the character's
absence from Black Panther wakanda
forever had more to do with the busy
schedule of the actor playing him than
the character himself it seems in the
months leading up to the November 2022
release of black panther wakanda forever
Marvel Cinematic Universe fans learned
relatively little about the film's plot
or cast it also wasn't totally clear how
wakanda forever would ultimately handle
the tragic 2020 death of Chadwick
Boseman who played King t'challa the
title character from 2018's Black
Panther but fans were comforted by the
information they did get Marvel
confirmed that many of the stars of
black panther would return in wakanda
Forever including Leticia Wright who
plays shuri Lupita Nyong'o who plays
Nakia and Martin Freeman who portrays CI
agent Everett Ross the movie also
introduces a number of new characters
such as tenochuertas neymor Dominique
Thorns Ruby Williams and Michaela Coles
Anika but not everyone from the first
movie returns in the sequel indeed one
of the most memorable supporting
characters from the first black panther
film is discussed dust but isn't present
in a tweet that is no longer public
Rotten Tomatoes Awards editor Jacqueline
Coley first revealed that actor Daniel
kaluya did not film any scenes as wakabi
for black panther wakanda forever Coley
said that kluya mentioned in an
interview that he was unable to reprise
his black panther role because of his
scheduling conflict with director Jordan
Peel's film nope variety later confirmed
this to be true it's a shame but it's um
I'm so happy to do it Galia plays one of
the lead characters in nope and the film
is his first collaboration with peel
since 2017's get out it seems the
Monumental re-teaming of actor and
director meant kuya had to pass up the
opportunity to appear in Black Panther
wakanda forever nevertheless wakanda
forever whethers culia's absence well
tying it into the events of the original
2018 film in that movie after being
initially introduced as a major
supporter of King t'challa Julia's
wakabi turns on the king as well as his
lover Okoye to support Eric killmonger
Stevens takeover of wakanda his own skin
and the spot has been alerted yes some
resistance to our new mission of course
killmonger's coup ultimately fails and
koye eventually confronts wakabi on the
battlefield okabe has no choice but to
surrender to her did you kill me my love
for wakanda
[Music]
without the question so even if kulia
had been able to appear in wakanda
Forever it's clear wakabi's actions in
the first movie would likely have
resulted in him having a reduced role in
the sequel okabe is absent from wakanda
forever but he does come up in dialogue
once in the scene in which Queen
raimonda strips a coye of her position
as general of the Dora milaje Rwanda
essentially implies that he's been
imprisoned for treason speaking to
Cinema Blend Black Panther and wakanda
forever director Ryan coogler revealed
just what wakabi is up to during the
events of wakanda forever saying he's
basically banished but still within
wakanda's borders if that makes sense
it's one line that refers to him still
being alive from the sound of it wakabi
is currently something of an
afterthought as far as the ongoing story
of the Black Panther universe is
concerned but coogler has confirmed that
wakabi is both alive and in wakanda that
leaves room for his return in either a
future black panther film or coogler's
upcoming wakanda-based Disney Plus show
should Clues a schedule once again allow
him to reprise his MCU character